it's funny you know you spend like all
of your 20s trying so so so so hard not
to get pregnant and then when you decide
that it's time that you would have any
trouble because it seems like it's such
a threat and you're like a new 20 do you
remember having that uh we met at a
series of parties I was like you're not
leaving until you give me your number
that was probably four years ago now we
started dating in May so four years old
yeah one day I saw a picture of Nathan
with a beard holding a baby and I was
like I think maybe this is the guy that
I need to have babies with we've been
living together for about two and a half
years when I got pregnant the first time
we told our family immediately we really
were like oh it's on this is this mrs.
Hamm what could go wrong
we had an ultrasound at about eight
weeks and the embryo didn't have a
heartbeat they said basically there's
not a fetus there it was like a total
shock
the ultrasound lady was like hmm so let
me go get the doctor I mean you know
rationally that what the doctors told
you is true but I think part of you is
still trying to figure out the solution
to the problem so I had a DNC which
stands for dissection and curettage I
didn't realize that I was going to be
continuing to bleed for the next two
weeks which was a constant reminder I
felt like a failure like I wasn't sure
um why this had happened to me I was so
excited to have a baby and it was like
like where do we go from here but I did
get pregnant again huh but I also had
another missed
and I talked to my doctor about it she
said it's a really good sign that it
means that you can get pregnant again
and then we did again after we did again
after that there was a sort of
miscarriage with each one two things
happen
the shock of it isn't as extreme because
you've been through it but you also
start to wonder is there something wrong
with our chemistry together is it maybe
just isn't going to happen there's a
hard time hard time for several weeks
months afterwards all it really took was
one quick google search and I found out
that I wasn't alone before I was
pregnant the first time I didn't really
know that many people who had had
miscarriages if you don't share with
people then you don't have a support
system we had decided to stop trying
yeah after a while and then two days
after that official choice we found out
that I was pregnant today I am eighteen
and a half weeks pregnant
we were like incredibly incredibly
cautious and we told nobody I refused to
believe that it was real until I saw a
heartbeat there was a lot of anxiety
leading up to the first ultrasound so
here we are at the doctor's office about
to have our tea ultrasound and I just
hope that
everything's in the right place went in
and yeah real haha genetic counselor
called me right away on the phone call
she was like n do you want to know the
sex and [ __ ] are we gonna find this out
right now
oh my goodness
oh are you ready no no yeah she goes was
awesome when we found out we are having
a baby girl girl
the second ultrasound we did another one
at 12 weeks yeah
the ultrasound technician was awesome
she was like look at her feet look
there's a hands there's a face and like
printing out numerous photos for us and
it was way more fun way more fun oh my
goodness there's like tons of action and
that's when we decided that it was gonna
be okay to tell our families yeah Nathan
cut out a cute little sign that said
like it's a girl then and then we
started the Skype with the monitor bent
down towards us or could they couldn't
see the wall and so we would kind of
hunch down with our faces cut off like
right here and then at a certain point
we tried to get them to say hey I can't
really see you that way yeah well I
couldn't wake up see half of Nathan's
head they can adjust your we're getting
worse you're cut off around your eyes a
key moment think tilted the screen back
and then we just kept talking 3 what is
happy so fill the screen a little yeah
there you go there go that's good Wow
you got to see them Billy look what wait
what's going on
you're a grandpa or will be oh I mean I
learned a lot during my first
pregnancies I guess I just want to say
like for other women and other couples
who are going through this you are not
alone so don't be afraid to reach out
don't be afraid to talk to your families
and your friends about it stay hopeful
keep your plans intact and just keep
working towards the result that you need
healthy pregnancies after miscarriage
are a total possibility